so we've got a riemann sum we're going
to take the limit as n approaches
infinity and the goal of this video is
to see if we can rewrite this as a
definite integral i encourage you to
pause the video and see if you can work
through it on your own
so let's remind ourselves how a definite
integral can relate to a riemann sum
so if i have the definite integral from
a
to b
of
f of x f of x
dx
we have seen in other videos this is
going to be the limit
as n approaches infinity
of
the sum capital sigma
going from i equals 1 to n and so we're
essentially going to sum the areas of a
bunch of rectangles
where the width of each of those
rectangles we can write as a delta x so
your width is going to be
delta x of each of those rectangles and
then your height is going to be the
value of the function
evaluated someplace in that delta x if
we're doing a right riemann sum we would
do the right end of that rectangle or of
that sub interval and so we would
start at our lower bound a
and we would add as many delta x's as
our index specifies so if i is equal to
1 we add 1 delta x so we'd be at the
right of the first rectangle if i is
equal to we add 2 delta x's so this is
going to be delta
x
times our index
so this is the general form that we have
seen before and so one possibility you
could even do a little bit of pattern
matching right over here our function
looks like the natural log function
so that looks like our f of x it's the
natural log
function so i could write that so f of x
looks like the natural log of x
what else do we see
well a
that looks like two
a is equal to two what would our delta x
be well you can see
this right over here this thing that
we're multiplying that just is divided
by n and it's not multiplying by an i
this looks like our delta x
and this right over here looks like
delta x times i so it looks like our
delta x is equal to
5 over n
so what can we tell so far
well we could say that okay this thing
up here
the original thing is going to be equal
to the definite integral we know our
lower bound is going from 2
to we haven't figured out our upper
bound yet we haven't figured out our b
yet but our function is the natural log
of x
and then
i will just write a dx here so in order
to complete writing this definite
integral i need to be able to write the
upper bound and the way to figure out
the upper bound is by looking at our
delta x because the way that we would
figure out a delta x for this riemann
sum here
we would say that delta x is equal to
the difference between our bounds
divided by how many sections we want to
divide it in divided by n so it's equal
to
b
minus a
b
minus a
over n
over
n
and so you can pattern match here if
this is delta x is equal to b minus a
over n let me write this down so this is
going to be equal to
b
b
minus our a which is 2
all of that over n
so
b
minus two
is equal to five
which would make b equal to seven
b is equal to seven
so there you have it we have our
original
our original limit our riemann limit or
limit of our riemann sum being rewritten
as a definite integral
and once again i want to emphasize why
this makes sense if we wanted to draw
this
it would look something like this i'm
going to try to hand draw
the
natural log function
it looks
something
like
this
this right over here would be one
and so let's say this is two and so
we're going from two
to seven this isn't exactly right
and so
our definite integral is concerned with
the area
under the curve from 2
until 7
and so this riemann sum you could view
as an approximation when n isn't
approaching infinity but what you're
saying is look when i is equal to 1 your
first one is going to be of with
5 over n so this is essentially saying
our difference between 2 and 7 we're
taking that distance 5 dividing it into
n rectangles
and so this first one
is going to have a width of 5 over n
and then what's the height going to be
well it's a right riemann sum
so we're using the value of the function
right over there
right at 2 plus 5 over n so this value
right over here
this is the natural log
the natural log of 2 plus
5 over n and since this is the first
rectangle times 1
times 1. and we could go keep going this
one right over here
the width is the same 5 over n
but what's the height
well the height here
this height right over here is going to
be the natural log of 2 plus 5 over n
times two
times two this is for
i is equal to two this is i is equal to
one and so hopefully you are seeing that
this makes sense the area of this first
rectangle is going to be natural log of
2 plus 5 over n times 1
times
5 over n
the second one over here natural log of
2 plus 5 over n times 2
times 5 over n and so with this is
calculating the sum of the areas of
these rectangles but then it's taking
the limit as n approaches infinity so we
get better and better approximations
going all the way to the exact area